having williamson asked to leave the
government does this relate to the leak
yes it looks like it does mark in fact
he's pretty much been sacked and it
seems that is in relation of course to
the leak and the leak enquiry that was
set up by Sir Mark said well said well
the cabinet secretary Downing Street
spokesman just released this statement
the Prime Minister has this evening
asked Kevin Williamson to leave the
government having lost confidence in his
ability to serve in the role of defense
as a defense secretary and as a member
of her cabinet the Prime Minister's
decision has been informed by his
conduct surrounding an investigation
into the circumstances of the
unauthorized disclosure of information
from a meeting of the National Security
Council the Prime Minister thanks all
members of the National Security Council
for their full cooperation and in candor
during the investigation and considers
the matter closed
so clearly absolutely no doubt now that
the defence secretary of this country
Gavin Williamson was involved in some
way with a leak from the National
Security Council the highest security
body in this country it is unprecedented
this sort of leak has never happened in
the entirety of the national security
council's existence since 2010 when it
was set up by the prime minister at that
time David Cameron and it seems that
none other than the defence secretary
the Prime Minister's a former PPS a very
close ally the person who effectively
ran her leadership campaign in 2016 who
was promoted to the position of defence
secretary when Michael Fallon was forced
to resign many people said that he
effectively proposed himself for that
job while his cabinet career is over and
I suspect his political career is
completely over as well and who knows it
is technically it is a crime to leak for
the National Security Council there had
been indications that the police might
be drawn in and it is entirely possible
in the criminal prosecution might even
follow of course we don't know for sure
if it was him or remember his team or
whatever but nonetheless the buck will
stop with him and it is entirely
possible that we might see as a result
of these leaks with regards to the
Chinese telecoms giant highway that he
has been involved in this their decision
to the decision to allow them in to be
involved in the construction of
Britain's 5g Network that decision being
leaked out before it was officially
announced it seems to govern Williamson
the defense secretary was responsible
I've also got Ben pastor
letter the Prime Minister has written to
mr. Williamson today they've obviously
met today because the letter says dear
Gavin thank you for your time this
evening we discussed the investigation
into the unauthorized disclosure of
information from the National Security
Council meeting on the 23rd of April
this is an extremely serious matter and
a deeply disappointing one the prime
minister writes it is vital for the
operation of good government to the UK's
national interest in some of the most
sensitive important areas that the
members of the NAC from our armed forces
our security intelligence agencies and
the most senior levels of government
able to have frank and detailed
discussions in full confidence that the
advice and analysis provided is not
discussed or divulged beyond that
trusted environment that is why I
commissioned the Cabinet Secretary to
establish an investigation if the
unprecedented leak from the NSC meeting
last week why I expect into everyone
connected to it ministers and officials
alike to comply with it fully you
undertook to do so and therefore concern
by the matter in which you have engaged
with this investigation it has been
conducted fairly with a full cooperation
of other NSC attendees they've all
answered questions engage properly
provided as much information as possible
to assist with the investigation courage
their others enesta to do the same your
conduct she says and I suspect this is a
crucial matter with regards to this has
not been of the same standards as others
in our meeting this evening I put you
the latest information from the
investigation which provides compelling
evidence suggesting your responsibility
for the unauthorized disclosure no other
credible version of events to explain
this leak has been identified it is
vital a full confidence in the members
of my cabinet and of the National
Security Council the gravity of this
issue alone and its ramifications for
the operation as the NEC wants a serious
steps we've taken an equally serious
response is therefore with great sadness
that I've concluded that I can no longer
have full confidence in you as Secretary
of State for defense and a minister in
my cabinet and I've asked you to leave
the government as you do so I would like
to thank you for the wider contribution
you've made over the last three years a
truly extraordinary letter mark I cannot
think of any equivalent like this
normally when you see even a minister
who's been sacked in perhaps a scandal
or sad or circumstances one thing's for
example the amber rod Windrush affair
last year the prime minister normally
gives glowing tribute to the person
service this is in no doubt a sacking of
the highest order and one which as the
Prime Minister said you have the defense
secretary of this country effectively
imperiling as she would say at national
security a truly extraordinary measure
that could have really very serious
political ramifications indeed for the
government